if you're a fan
of r scott backer the epic fantasy
writer
and philosopher and you'd like to get in
on some second apocalypse action then
you
are going to want to join us coming up
this saturday
at noon central time that saturday april
10th where we're going to be discussing
the work the warrior prophet this is
episode
51 of the worlds of speculative fiction
series that i've been
carrying on now for this is the sixth
year
of the series and we started last month
talking about the prince of nothing
trilogy that he wrote very philosophical
a lot of really cool themes going on
so we're going to be continuing on this
month with the warrior prophet and then
next month with a thousand-fold thought
check it out if you want to join us
first we have a video premiere
that is going to go on for about an hour
45
and then following that we'll have a
zoom session where we talk about some of
the key
philosophical themes and world building
and characters and plot points and all
sorts of other cool stuff
in this book i hope you can join me and
if not then you know check out the video
after it
airs there's a lot of interesting things
that we're going to be
going over in it